[موسيقى]
قبل صلاه العربيه كان هناك صباح العقيد
انا بشكر انه يوم الانطلاقه بثلاثه
كان يوم ربيعي ومشمس وجميل
بس كان العالم عم يغلي حتى كانه الكره
الارضيه موضوعه على صفيح ساخن
هلا كان كل شي جاهز لننطلق بالنشره الاولى
اللي هي كانت الساعه عشره بتوقيت جرينتش
يعني الساعه الواحده بعيده الظهر في توقيت
مكه المكرمه وكان الي شرف انه انا اطلق
النشر الاولى في قناه العربيه وهذه لحظه
انا ما بنساها تحضيرات كانت ضخمه
تحديات كبيره يعني لوجستيه فنيا تقنيا
لانه اخذنا مرحله كبيره من
التحضيرات ولكن كان في فكره واحده عم
بتهيمن على دهن الجميع انه العالم بحاجه
الى العربيه ففي ذلك التاريخ ولدت العربي
الفرنسيه عن وزير
وفي كلمه من بغداد ومعنى شيئا فشيئا ولكن
بسرعه حولت العربيه الاعلام العربيه الى
الابد المعادله بسيطه المعلومه قبل كل شيء
كان لابد ان تغير نبض الصباح وهكذا تجرات
العربيه ذات صباح وولد صباح العربي
ينطلق بعد قليل برنامج جديد على شاشه
العربيه برنامج صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعدتم صباحا واهلا بكم الى صباح العربيه
الاول احلى صباح من ابرز ماسن نناقشه صباح
اليوم التاسع من يوليو هل تحدد فصيله دمك
الشخصيتك منذ ايام اخضعت نفسي لنظريه
يابانيه حددت شخصيتي وزميلتنا لليان ستعلق
بين الارض والسماء في مغامره ما كنت شخصيا
لاجرا على القيام بها ثوره اعلاميه صغيره
ولدت في الطابق الارضي لمبنى ام بي سي
والعربيه قال اريكه جميله اردنا ان نسكن
في بيوت الناس ان يصبحوا حديثنا ونصبح
حديثنا ان يصبحوا جديدنا ونصبح جديدهم ان
نصبح القريبين وان يصبحوا الاقرب فما
الاخبار ان لم تكن من الناس
ومن اجل الناس لكن نحن كنا الرابحين ايضا
اردنا ان شاشتنا تتسع لاكثر للموسيقى
والفنون للابداع والجنون للمشاهير
لايف اول مره
اهلا بكم معنا في هذه الحلقه الجديده من
صباح العربيه
صباحكم سعيد من برنامج صباح العربيه يوم
جديد وحلقه جديده من صباح العربيه
[موسيقى]
كل موسم كان موسم صباح العربيه تتالت
السنين توالى المذيعون وتراكم الحنين حتى
بلغنا العشرين وسيبقى في ذاكره العربيه
وذاكره مشاهديها ذكرى من تاريخ لم ينتهي
بعد وامال لمستقبل لم ياتي بعد صباح
العربيه صباح دائم اسعد الله صباحكم بكل
خير واهلا بكم الى حلقه
جديده اهلا بك سهام واهلا بمشاهدي صباح
العربيه اينما كنتم
[موسيقى]